-After Tesla and SpaceX
C.E.O. Elon Musk's
acquisition of Twitter, one of
the big political questions
looming over the platform is
whether Donald Trump
will get his account back.
Meanwhile, progressives
are sounding the alarm
about billionaire control
of media and big-tech companies.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm guessing by now
most of you have heard the news
about Twitter,
unless you're not on Twitter,
in which case congratulations
on having a life,
because Twitter has stolen mine.
Do you guys remember
when Twitter started
and the big complaint was people
posting pictures of their food?
Just remember, it can
always get worse than food.
It's like when your Aunt goes on
forever about
her favorite restaurant, and
you think, "This story sucks,"
and then your
uncle starts talking about
how tough white people have it
and you realize you miss
the restaurant story.
[ Laughter ]
In fact,
when it comes to Twitter,
I wish I had the same
approach to posting
that actor Michael Caine has.
On Monday, he tweeted
out of nowhere,
after several months of silence,
"Hello!"
And then almost immediately
followed that up
with a second tweet that said,
"Good Night My Sweet Ones."
[ Laughter ]
And hasn't tweeted since.
He popped in,
took one look around,
and then he just
got the hell out of there.
I imagine that Michael Caine
checking out what was going on
with Twitter
looked a lot like this.
-Go.
[ Explosion ]
[ Clattering ]
-[ British accent ]
"Elon, you were only supposed
to blow the bloody doors off."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normally ] We asked ourselves,
"Can we shoehorn
a Michael Caine impression
into 'A Closer Look' today?"
And the answer was,
"Yes, we Caine."
[ Laughter ]
Among the many questions
now looming over Twitter
after Musk's acquisition
of the company
is whether Donald Trump,
who used his Twitter account
to foment coups,
direct harassment,
disseminate dangerous lies,
disinformation and racism,
will get his account back.
For his part, Trump himself
has said
that even if he's allowed
to return, he won't.
-Ever since Elon Musk first
raised the prospect
a couple weeks ago
that he might buy Twitter,
speculation has swirled that,
among other things,
this could result in the
former president, Donald Trump,
rejoining the social-media site.
Trump, of course,
was banned from Twitter
January of last year
for using the site
to try to foment a violent
insurrection
to overthrow
the U.S. government.
In response to the speculation
that he might be reinstated
to the platform, under an Elon
Musk-owned version of Twitter,
Trump himself
has reportedly said
that he won't rejoin Twitter,
even if he's allowed to.
-I'm sorry, but there's no way
Trump won't immediately
go back to tweeting
if he's given the chance.
He'll go back to tweeting with
the same energy
Marty McFly
went back to the future,
which makes sense
because compared to Twitter,
Truth Social
feels like kissing your mom.
And I think that joke really
illustrates the...
-♪ Power of love ♪
-Can you feel it?
Plus, Trump doesn't have
the self-restraint
to stay off Twitter.
Offering him his Twitter back
is like offering
Keith Richards a cigarette.
"Yeah, I'm already smoking one,
but alright.
I guess that's what
these two fingers are for."
[ Laughter ]
Twitter was Trump's lifeblood.
He once called himself
the Ernest Hemingway of Twitter.
And according to Politico,
he used to marvel
at how quickly his tweets
appear on the television screen.
He's like a cat in a science
experiment who figures out,
if he rings the bell,
he gets a treat.
[ Bell jingles ]
[ Laughter ]
"Ring the bell, get a treat.
It's one of the best deals
I've ever made.
It's -- 'Cause ringing the bell,
it costs me nothing. So easy.
And the treat, let me tell you
about the treats.
There's tuna.
There's tuna,
and there's chicken."
[ Laughter ]
And let me just say
for the record
that while banning Trump
from Twitter
has always been complicated,
I think it would be terrible,
certainly for me,
if Trump got his Twitter back.
Mainly, not having him on
Twitter has just been
a huge
quality-of-life improvement.
Although I will admit,
there have been times when,
against my better instincts,
I have wondered
what Trump would have tweeted
during big-news stories,
less for the awful opinions
and more for the weird grammar
and punctuation.
Like, can you imagine
what he would have said
about Will Smith at the Oscars?
[ Laughter ]
But Trump claims
he still wants to steer people
toward his dumb
social media platform,
which has had a rocky roll-out,
including bugs and glitches
that have made it difficult
for people to join.
And it can't help that Trump
himself seems incapable
of remembering
or even pronouncing
the name of his own site,
which is called Truth Social,
as we learned during
a Trump rally in Ohio last week.
-They conspired to ban me from
every social media platform
on the face of the Earth.
Millions and millions of you
had already experienced
big tech's vicious censorship.
Because of this digital tyranny,
we had to give the American
people their voice back
by building something
called "troth" --
"truth senchal."
[ Laughter ]
-And it's just amazing.
He got mad at Twitter
and made up his own version
out of pure vengeance,
and he can't even remember
what it's called.
[ Laughter ]
This is like if Darth Vader
was giving a speech
to unveil the Death Star and
said, "[Crackles]
Soon, the universe
will bow to the Empire.
I give you the...
Kill Ball?
[ Laughter ]
Death Ball?
Kevin?
Is Kevin back there?
What is it, again?
But it's not really a star,
though, is it, Kevin?
No, oh, no, I get it.
'Ball' is not great.
Thank you, Kevin."
[ Laughter ]
Also, could we just watch
that clip one more time?
-We had to give the American
people their voice back
by building something
called "troth" --
"truth senchal."
-The best is in his head.
He's like, "I'm glad
I saved that 'troth' part."
[ Laughter ]
"Stumbled on 'troth,'
but then got it back."
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, everyone should join
Donald Trump's new social media
platform, Truth Central.
Truth Central sounds like the
name of a law enforcement agency
in a dystopian sci-fi movie
where Tom Cruise arrests people
for crimes before they happen.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe that explains
why Rudy Giuliani always looks
like a precog who just woke up.
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to be a precog...
to know we were gonna use
that picture of Rudy again.
[ Laughter ]
Let me save you
all the slime bath.
And maybe Trump's
inability to advertise
his own social media site
is hurting its success
because they're clearly
desperate for people to sign up.
On Tuesday, the C.E.O.
of Truth Social,
former Congressman Devin Nunes,
perhaps
the world's only postcog,
pleaded with the hosts of
"Fox & Friends" to join the site
and reveal their version
of the word "tweet is truth,"
meaning that a post on the site
is known as a truth,
and posting a truth
is known as "truthing,"
which is, of course,
incredibly dumb
and sounds even dumber
coming out of Nunes' mouth.
-We're so excited
that you're on Truth.
You're getting followers
very, very quickly,
but you need to
send some truths out
if you want to get
more followers.
But also, Brian, you're on
Truth, we need you to truth.
But Doocy, I got to talk to him.
So he's got to turn his phone on
and click on the app.
He's been let in.
-Every time you think
your life is bad, just remember,
you can be a former Congressman
begging Brian Kilmeade,
a man with the eyes of a Cabbage
Patch doll, to send out truths.
Nunes sounds like
he should be in a phone booth,
begging his bookie
to let him place one more bet.
"Oh, come on, Ricky.
You know I'm good for it.
I got a horse
who's a guaranteed winner!
I want to put
a million bucks on him.
They call him Truth.
Central Truth?
No, wait, the Truth Star?
Oh, God,
don't hang up on me, Ricky!
Ricky!"
[ Laughter ]
Nunes always looks like he
should be crying in his car
in the parking lot
of Lumon Industries.
That's our second reference
to "Severance,"
the Apple TV show that has
taken the "Late Night" offices
by storm.
The first was on Monday,
and based on the response from
the audience, it seemed like
not everyone was caught up.
But it's Wednesday now,
so to update us
on where you are in regards
to "Severance," do please go to
@seacaptainpolls on Twitter,
where the options will be,
"yes, I'm caught up now,"
"no, I'm still behind,"
or "who the [bleep]
is the Sea Captain?"
And just to show you
how bad the bugs are
in Trump's Truth Social app,
later in the interview, Fox host
Steve Doocy did as instructed.
He opened his phone
and told Nunes he was still
in a waiting list
to join the app.
-Congressman, I'm looking.
I just signed on, and it says
I have been created
successfully.
"Due to massive demand, we have
placed you on a wait list."
I'm number 621,000, still.
-A waiting list?
Isn't the whole point
of the Internet
that everything is instant?
This is like if
you clicked on Apple Maps
and it was just a list of places
where you can buy a map.
[ Laughter ]
But even with their own social
media platform at stake,
Trump, Nunes,
and their fellow Republicans
are still celebrating the news
about Tesla and SpaceX C.E.O.
Elon Musk
finalizing a deal
to buy Twitter.
And I have to say,
it's certainly
an interesting decision
from a business perspective
to say the least,
given that Twitter
is not even profitable.
-Elon Musk
is taking over Twitter
to the tune of $44 billion.
After weeks
of corporate wrangling,
Twitter's board of directors
accepting
the billionaire's buyout offer
in a unanimous vote.
-What do we know
about Elon Musk's plans
to monetize Twitter,
a company
that hasn't made a profit
for 8 of the past 10 years?
-One of the consistent issues
that Twitter has had
for a very long time has been
making this company
consistently profitable.
And for a very long time,
that hasn't been the case.
But I think this is really
more about ideology for Elon.
-Musk has, according to him,
raised about $13 billion
from Morgan Stanley.
He's got another $12.5 billion
he will help fund with loans
against his Tesla stock.
And he's adding $21 billion
of his own cash.
-$44 billion?
I mean, with money like that,
you could do something about
poverty or climate change
or world hunger
and still have enough left over
to, I don't know,
get a decent haircut?
[ Laughter ]
It looks like Tesla isn't
the only thing that uses plugs.
Please don't kick me off
Twitter, Elon, please!
It's the only place I can go
where people call me a cuck.
I know it's a crazy thing to
like, but...
classic cuck behavior, right?
[ Laughter ]
So, obviously,
there are potentially
some really bad outcomes here.
But regardless of whether
you're pro-Musk or anti-Musk,
let's maybe
take a step back and reconsider
whether it's a good thing
that everyone's just rooting
for different billionaires
like sports teams,
which are also owned
by billionaires,
a fact, I've been
reminded of repeatedly
by my crew after
hedge-fund titan Steve Cohen
bought the Mets, who now have
the most wins in baseball.
And seeing how it's April,
that should hold up.
[ Laughter ]
Famously, the Mets are in
October what they are in April.
Yesterday, after the Mets won
their sixth series in a row,
our security guard, Jim Bryer,
came up to me weeping
and said, "This is
the greatest day of my life."
And then I asked him
what the second-best day was,
and he said,
"When you got COVID."
Not cool, Jim.
[ Laughter ]
Not cool.
Not that I'd ever say that
to his face.
I mean, look at the guy.
I was talking to what I thought
was Jim for 20 minutes,
and it turned out it was
just a rock in Central Park.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Maybe, just maybe, it's not
healthy for our democracy
when Twitter, Facebook,
and "The Washington Post"
are all owned by some of
the richest men in the world,
not to mention the fact that
Fox, "The Wall Street Journal,"
and a network of right-wing
media outlets are owned
by another
right-wing billionaire
who's on the list of the
100 richest people in the world.
That's not a free market.
That's an oligarchy,
which is why workers
at major companies
like Amazon and Starbucks
are trying to win back power
by unionizing,
a movement that's growing
stronger by the day.
Bernie Sanders and A.O.C.
rallied with Amazon workers
in Staten Island
over the weekend,
and Bernie recently took to
the Senate floor
to champion the reinvigorated
union movement,
in typical Bernie fashion.
-Unions provide better wages,
benefits, and working conditions
for their members.
That is what unions do.
Not complicated.
That is why it makes sense
to join a union
and why it makes sense for us
to do everything that we can
to grow the trade-union movement
in this country.
And I know there are
some folks out there
who are not union members
and they're saying,
"Well, it doesn't really
impact me."
You're wrong. It does.
-I love when Bernie cuts through
the bull[bleep].
I wish they would have let him
host "Jeopardy!"
"What is the Spanish Armada?"
"You're wrong."
"Aren't you, um --
Aren't you supposed to tell us
the right answer now?"
"If you want to know
the right answers,
you should have studied harder.
Now pick a category,
or I'll pick it for you!"
[ Laughter ]
No one knows how Musk's
acquisition of Twitter
will turn out or whether Trump
will return to the platform
and what the effect of that
will be.
But one thing
we can know for sure
is that this much power
and wealth
in the hands of so few people
is definitely bad for democracy.
We need a system that relies
less on the power of money
and more on the...
-♪ Power of love ♪
[ Cheers and applause,
light laughter ]
-When it barely got a reaction
the first time,
did you think, "Oh, no,
that's our callback"?
[ Laughter ]
You know what this means, Sal?
You know where you
and I have to go.
Back to the future!
[ Laughter ]
"Don't do the
'Power of Love' joke!"
[ Laughter ]
Let's see, we did a little
Michael Caine.
We got that in there.
Keith Richards.
[ Muttering indistinctly ]
I think we got everything.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illness,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.